skins very try I mean moisturize yes
okay it's very bumpy hi I'm Garrett I'm
Nikki
we're fascinated by how other people
live sir being try and find some really
interesting living situations and live
they're experiencing a totally different
lifestyle
see which one's bring us closer together
or push us further apart this week we're
living in an RV why'd you emphasize it
like that I don't know I drove it here
[Music]
hi my name is David and this is my RV
it's a 32 foot it's six people very very
comfortably I never had anybody take my
RV out and say we didn't have a good
time that's usually an experience that
they didn't expect and plan on doing so
again in the future because they had
such a fun time hi I'm David we're
spending three days in an RV driving
around Arizona when you think of RV I
think the destination you think of is
the Grand Canyon I think it's gonna be a
perfect if we're going somewhere I want
to get there efficiently and quickly RVs
are all about taking your time taking
the scenic route like if we want to go
see the Grand Canyon let's just go see
the Grand Canyon a lot of people live in
these things
my grandparents spent like months at a
time in an RV I don't get it it's not
efficient inconvenient slow oh okay
where do you think it wow yeah I think
this is really gonna put Garrett's eyes
to the test because there's no space
unless I'm six seven people we got to
start living bigger I know everybody's
like trying to downsize and stuff to
stop it now this is the slide we're
gonna extend it right now
what getting bigger that's amazing
obviously there's not a lot of room
inside of it there's only one like
actual bed but then I think a bunch of
other places fold out into beds which is
neat like a lot of things that have dual
purposes you need over here but this
also turns into a bed it'll probably be
where you're sleeping I will measure it
they feed across so you have plenty of
room up there yeah oh my gosh it's super
long Wow we were so worried about you
has a shower bathroom I measured it it
is actually 6/10 oh really Wow well
that's gonna be great exactly come in
here I want to show you guys something
right here disasters
I have not has anyone else they have not
okay the kitchen is complete it's
everything that you would expect inside
of your kitchen you got a frigerator and
freezer here Oh like a kitchen it is
absolutely our kitchen we're in a car
and it's like safe to cook in here
absolutely when you move everything
needs to be fastened down pretty much
pretty much you're you're gonna hear
some rattles on the road no it's okay
okay so I don't know how the RV works
like it's got a water tank it's got
electricity like do we need to charge it
like a Tesla the only context I have for
RVs are what I've seen in movies I'm
just really worried about a poop
situation happening okay fun part is
that the poop hole Vicki I want sure we
get that down you're gonna have sewer
electricity and water matches back on
normally when you pull up and you'll
have a hole on the ground and stuff like
that you'll see a rock next to it okay
it's there for a reason all right you
put this in the hole don't don't nothing
that's not what having an IceCube movie
given where our relationship is now I
think spending all this time together an
RV will actually push us together
it is such like an obstacle thing it's
like we've really worked together to
accomplish living in this motor vehicle
with this living situation there are too
many obstacles I think we're gonna be at
each other's throats all right
here busy it's like fast and everything
down while we're driving
oh you already falling over you're just
gonna sleep the whole time I Drive
aren't you yeah I'm not like a bad
driver but this thing is so big Garrett
can drive it
this is his size the vehicle you sure
you can drive this thing we're gonna
find out our way to the Grand Canyon on
a scale of 1 to 10 how scared are you
right now this turn
I don't you got it I can't see you the
drive wasn't so bad a lot of vehicle
won't hit that car I think I will not
only use up you driving a bus yes look
at me this is finally like a you sized
vehicle Wow you're doing a great job I'm
gonna go take a nap in the back
am I allowed to be back here while
you're driving the people in the car
behind us can definitely see me
well Garrett was driving this afternoon
and I like laid down back here but it's
like a really bumpy ride so everything
just felt like super crazy and
everything was shaking I actually was
like really happy that Nicky was able to
like lay down and nap while I was
driving and like be comfortable because
then it doesn't feel as cramped it
doesn't feel as sort of arduous as a
road trip can feel at first I was very
nervous driving this thing but then
after just like 10 miles I was very
comfortable doing it we made it Garrett
drove us to the Grand Canyon could've
done it without you asleep in the back
Nick it was so bumpy it's very dark and
I have no idea where we are
but now we got to go hook up the poop
hose so Gary can poop I don't think
Eric's used the bathroom yet I think
he's scared welcome to my crib there's
the water what do we do first we did
Perry okay that's very power but which
one's dirty there were a few like
learning hiccups about how to hook up
this machine transformer bus goes in
both ways and it doesn't turn either way
let's do the water hooking it up to the
system was like a little weird alright
it's accepting it we have water it seems
to be leaking leave it maybe shut it off
for a second we had a couple hiccups but
I think that's just because we'd never
done it before now if we like had to
hook this thing up to any place anywhere
in the country I think we'd be able to
do it without issue there you go we've
done it RV Garrett and I are really
figuring out each other's quirks I think
he eats like a fourteen-year-old all he
wants to eat our cheeseburgers all right
well it's going great yeah it always
feels great for you because you just sit
and watch me cook there's no space for
me to help you you want me to stand
right next to you and watch burgers
Brown yes no sit down and they can I
started getting in like tiny little
fights a little bit on each other and
it's fine sit back all he makes dinner
and does all the dishes those look
pretty good Nick why stop doing it still
ventilation okay well now we found
something for you to do it's maybe even
a sign of friendship progress when you
can get in little fights with your
friends and know that that's going to be
fine not that that's a good thing what I
only try to do stuff he'll be like oh
why would you do it that way I'll do it
he wants to be in control and he wants
to be in charge so I'm sick of cooking
dinner for her so tomorrow we'll get out
first sunrise yeah tomorrow let's see
the sunrise over the Grand Canyon well
okay good night Nikki
[Music]
well it's the morning on the first day
we're going to miss the sunrise over the
Grand Canyon I think this was a pretty
optimistic plan to begin with because I
don't think Nikki's ever seen the
sunrise I'm gonna still try to get this
thing unhooked so that we can drive
around the Grand Canyon for the day well
we're all unhooked ready to see the
sunrise over the Grand Canyon looks like
it's already pretty risen meanwhile
Nikki sleeps
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Here I am the grand Caymans Wow so it's
about a 30 you think Garrett drove was
some more because we're definitely
moving
I guess he's seen the Grand Canyon by
himself which is kind of frustrating I
know that I kind of made it so that our
plan fell through like the least he
could've done I'm like hey I'm gonna
drive us across the park is that cool
there's no water so he decided to do all
of this on his own and now I'm kind of
trapped he's very much used to kind of
doing things on a whim it just so
happens is that him deciding to do
something by himself Falls and I'm like
dragging me along in the back while I
was half asleep so you were awake when
we were driving you didn't want to ask
what we were doing how I don't know
saying anything we're all in one room
you were asleep and when we go up she
was sort of usually unilaterally decided
to do stuff we made a plan to see the
Grand Canyon then she didn't wake up but
I'm trying not to become defensive about
things okay
behold the Grand Canyon parking lot so
you slept pretty good were you cold no
it's fine
did you use that electric blanket yeah
plays really gonna be bad if you don't
like this thing why wouldn't I like it I
don't know god it's huge it's pretty big
in it
parted rounds pretty cool I don't know
how things are between us now like if
we've taken a step back or if we're back
to where we were
I don't think we'll know until tomorrow
I was frustrated and I was upset I just
need a little bit sometimes and then I
can participate and then I can be
involved and I can be invested but Grand
Canyon is kind of amazing Wow
that said there's really not much to do
but look at it oh all right
eggs the kitchen is I'd say like not the
worst kitchen we've had to live with
this - gasps oh is one guess once I
guess turn it off they're all off I'm
starting to understand a little bit more
why people enjoy RVs and there's
definitely been parts of this experience
that I've enjoyed but a lot of it's
still very challenging for me actually
living this RVs been a little bit rocky
er than I thought it was going to be
we'll see tomorrow if it's really like
brought us together actually sort of
done damage to our relationship I think
I made the coffee too strong nosers then
[Music]
as now what it should taste like next
time you decide to drive the band can
you talk
I want to let you sleep okay well when
you drive and don't sleep tell me if you
can wake me up okay try to wake you up
oh my knees get you little stool yeah
thanks for doing dishes thanks for
trying
I don't think either of us knew the type
of relationship investment we were
getting into when we decided to live in
this RV together over the course of the
day though like you got better Nikki
come on go for a ride
[Music]
look at her go
fun yeah so I have enough room in this
bathroom to do my hair which is nice
quarters are a little tight still but I
can at least do this
okay and we're gonna take a shower how
am I gonna do this this is taking some
planning we've gotten really good at
like connecting the house up
- it's like inputs which seemed like
something that we would never get good
at or still feel buttons and stuff that
I don't know I don't work so I'm very
thankful that Garrett knows how to use
them and work them because he's been
kind of taking the reins on being in
charge functioning the vehicle water
power TV RV high five shall we transform
the area you want transform into beds
yeah
tomorrow we have a lot of work to do to
clean up the RV and to pack up and to
get out of here we are going to refold
everything up
unhook everything nose bleeding are you
still filming this you [ __ ] morning of
the third day hopefully Nikki will wake
up and make us coffee
this has been a very interesting
experience we're gonna go I definitely
understand the purpose that it serves
and I totally understand why there are
so many are views in this park right now
with Happy's head management challenge
this is probably the most different
living style we've have done it's all in
all a small space but pretty efficient
really had everything we needed to live
this feels like something you do with
people that you know you can piss off to
no end and have them still love you at
the end of the day I don't know if we're
there yet and I don't know if this was
good for us this whole thing rocks when
you walk back and forth I don't think
this RV brought us closer together
it almost pushed us further apart a
challenge I don't know where we go from
here I think he and I are really ready
to be alone and to be apart from each
other right now I just need to know that
she's never gonna wake up for a sunrise
what am I thinking
the Grand Canyon is breathtaking it's
unbelievable
nothing does it justice except for going
there and standing on the edge of being
like oh my god and you got to do it at
least once you don't have to live your
life however you want this experience
has been very beautiful we're seeing
with part of the countries that I've
never seen before
the Grand Canyon is unbelievable driving
through it's been really fun that said I
want to get back to my house so badly
next week on homebodies Arcosanti what
is it it's almost as if we're like
citizens of a new city we'll have you
work in construction tomorrow can I ask
how much rent is $300 less Wow I don't
think Nikki's gonna like this I'm
getting some like podshare vibes I'm
really afraid that at the end of three
days I'm not gonna know what this was
you